ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show in New York City I'm I was
here to do a show in Philly which was
great thank you to everybody for coming
out to Parks Casino and I'm at the Miami
Improv November 17th through the 19th
and this is our final guest of the year
the rest are we're we're we're back to
solo episodes but we wanted to get you
in Ari shaffir
thanks buddy tell the truth Park Casino
full of fat disgusting people though
right
um I mean Casino people are like gutter
the people that my Tracy fat Tracy okay
hosted the show she brought in yeah four
or five women after the show to take a
photo one woman had a gold chain like
the one Mr T used to wear oh tied around
her fupa
I mean the most disgusting but you know
I'm sure the rest of the audience was
lovely but that one woman
I mean it was wild but but but full of
life oh no they're having a good time
they're having a good time they're out
at a casino yeah in their 11.99 meals
you're special I have had three
different people call me and go this
thing is so [ __ ] good oh hell yeah
it's amazing you've worked on it for
five years
it has a theme
the theme is Jews the theme is taken
over the theme is Jews it couldn't be
more relevant right now
um I feel like people just discovered us
because of Kanye put us over yeah the
way P Diddy would do with mace yeah
why did you want to do an hour about the
most hated group of people on earth I
just throw the pot I guess that's a good
question uh I went to Edinburgh they all
do these dumb [ __ ] theme hours and
they're so bad at it yeah it always gets
serious for so long well it's always
like uh an hour is like I was
misgendered at a Fruit Stand yeah or
somebody's doing it from a treadmill the
whole time or it's just like some weird
thing I was misgendered for since the
end of my life right someone in a text
thread called me [ __ ] and that's an
hour yeah it's an hour about this one
nothing moment they always should have
over push the drama and you get Miss Pat
who just skates by her rape you know you
don't even like wait what did she just
say yeah she was hit with a dump truck
yeah and she doesn't even really dwell
on it well the dump truck didn't do
farewell right it's a good point yeah
what what was it about were you just
like I wanna how Jewish even are you I
don't even think of you as that you look
very Jewish but I don't think of you as
a committed shoot I'm out that's the
deal I'm out I'm not committed at all I
don't give a [ __ ] about those people I
do I care about them a little bit but
like you have to cultural that's it I
look for bargains yeah little things you
can't shake you know from your childhood
you must see like a you know
construction company and you go oh [ __ ]
I can own that
yeah I mean my I well my people are
Irish so I feel a kinship with my people
100 I'm not going on Long Island on Long
Island I feel a kinship with criminals
and people that do prescription drugs
yeah contractors no but I feel people
the people that you grew up around are
the people that you love yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what it is so I just wanted
to show everybody what they were and
what are they they're they're just like
everybody else just that's not true
they're a bit they're better we value
education yeah we're not born
intelligent it might be genetic let's be
honest there's no there's not many
studies on it
but we are smarter aren't the IQs of
Ashkenazi Jews very high extremely high
I mean is that any surprise no bro
Woody Allen wrote his own movies
a lot of these guys just take on someone
else's project you think Michael Bay
even knows how to write
no he doesn't yeah he just has special
effects
yeah we're extremely intelligent we
value education we stick to ourselves we
[ __ ] you know raise our kids right
when you hear Kanye throw out all these
things it's collusion the people they're
working together against the others
do you understand at all where he comes
from yeah we help ourselves we all went
to like Jewish like dentists and stuff
right you know it's just like you know
support support this is what [ __ ]
Killer Mike says about black people
right how come you don't support each
other's business so we're like yeah we
know we figured it out there seems to be
a tough relationship between Jewish
music Executives and black performers
yeah here's why we designed everything
they do that do rag that 50 Cent had
that's you designed really we choose all
that [ __ ] they run it by us and then we
chose what will we do market research
and we just figure out what's the best
Milli Vanilli it was all Jews who were
singing this stuff right we've just like
planned it but we know we're not cool
looking
and also yeah we kill it in the in the
management industry you know why why
comedy managers and agents are Jews why
why the the record because you need to
be having someone funneling your money
the first three years you're not making
any money right who else could afford
that only Rich right no
well this that's good follow your dream
these are all good things good things
but here's the thing also yeah because I
grew up with Jews yeah on Long Island oh
there's tons whom I love Yeah loud
they're a little loud obnoxious
complainy for sure complainers yeah but
you need in an area where there are no
Jews and Italians there's no good food
because wasps yeah will not complain
because they don't want to look a waiter
in the eye because they feel so above
them they don't even complain a Jewish
person will will go back there yes we'll
go back to hey no no no right so switch
it yeah absolutely I was at the
Galapagos and the guy was like uh I
mentioned I was Jewish he goes is that
like Israeli I'm like yeah sure he goes
I've had three Israelis to hear and they
just go to the kitchen
they just go and cook themselves stuff
you know right and I'm like yeah yeah
why would we wait why is there so much
anti-semitism
it's kind of like why people hate the
Patriots right they win they win right
yeah no one hates cambodians
no I'm kidding I don't even know you
know yeah yeah there is a lot I saw
Brian wholesome you know Holtzman right
of course you saw some uh Jewish lady in
the front Royals what are you Jewish she
goes yeah he goes why does everybody
hate you yeah she goes I don't know he
goes hey you think you'd ask if
everybody hated me yeah I might ask is
the hour about being a Jew all of it
being a Jew what Judaism is the laws the
history the Bible stories where does
Judaism come from I'm genuinely curious
who was the first Jew
um good question I guess Abraham right
yeah
yeah Abraham was prom yeah Abraham was
the first Jew before that everybody was
equal
do you know you go to heaven without
even having to do what we do
well you don't believe in heaven I don't
Jews don't choose no we believe in
heaven we don't believe in hell
oh Purgatory we got Purgatory only I'm a
Christian which is a perfected Jew
because Jesus came and Colter said that
once oh Jesus came and said
I'm dying for your sins and you guys
said
we're gonna did you guys do it or did
the Romans kill Jesus who killed Jesus
we don't get our hands dirty right it's
a good point yeah you know who built the
deck oh I built a deck in my house I
built a new no Mexicans did it when you
go to Israel do you feel a kinship do
you feel because when I go to Dublin
Ireland I go yeah I see everyone looks
like a potato I get it yeah yeah yeah
for sure they're so much tougher there
though yeah they're living in the
[ __ ] on the edge all the time you've
been there ever ever you got to do one
that's obviously you're too dirty to go
on one of those gigs I am too what are
the they're living on the edge because
of what war any moment there's gonna be
a [ __ ] bombing
you know Tel Aviv Israel yeah I haven't
heard about this the Middle East they're
so calm I heard an old prime minister or
whatever he said what's the problem in
the middle is he goes America's looking
at it like oh we'll trade you some land
for peace whatever and he goes you know
gold or whatever whatever you don't want
to do to trade he goes there they're
operating on a different thing they go
our God told us to kill you right you
can't really negotiate how do you fix
that and I won't hold you to this but
like many people say kill them all right
I don't right you mean in them all you
mean the Palestinians they both think
the same way right yeah yeah yeah
they're both like yeah well who's that
have you gone to the Gaza Strip no I go
by that they do they used to take you on
buses apart like armed cars like you
know bars in the windows
rocks would start throwing at you it was
crazy it's the [ __ ] front lines yeah
it's 20 years ago last time I went to
like places like that but is it fair
what Israel did
terrible dude those people live poor I
mean it comes from a place there's like
real war
we took him over from from [ __ ]
Jordan and Jordan's like we don't want
them
right he's like come get your refugees
back like nah they're your problem
though imagine if Mexico attacked and we
drove them back you know 50 yards and
we're like all right well these are all
yours Mexico's like nah it's like all
those tijuanas
yeah it's a difficult
thing
because it's best not to think about it
bury your head in the sand is the best
one one Viewpoint is the Viewpoint that
I have which is I don't I don't care
that's me I'm unaffected yeah
and I don't
know how to fix it I don't have any
opinion on how to fix it yeah that's the
Viewpoint that's the Viewpoint it's like
homelessness and the people that well
how did you fix them like I'm not in
charge of that right what the f I don't
know I
get a home you nuts I mean these people
without homes it's insane yeah you want
to live in Manhattan so bad you can't
live here the prices are too hard
haven't you seen the movies where people
are in a house with a Fire doesn't that
look better than that tent you're not
they're goons you think the first person
to give them a tent be like oh I have an
idea I have an old tent I'll give it to
like they didn't used to happen I don't
even believe these people are homeless I
think they're just making a point what's
the point
they're like [ __ ] I don't know they
want to be special
Outlaws they want to be special so
they're like oh I live in a tent you're
like we get it but it's not even special
anymore everybody's doing it it's like
being into a Lotus the first year I get
it yeah I'm sick of homelessness I won't
tolerate it I won't tolerate any
discussion of it I will pretend it
doesn't exist until I am homeless very
soon you ever go to another city where
homeless is new and and then some
homeless guy will come up and talk to
you just like ignore him and keep
talking be like how do you do that yeah
like oh practice oh yeah I'm a pro at it
now LA's got 40 000 homeless people is
that true they're a voting block they
have a Kansas City of homeless in L.A
but you ignore it then I'll vote they
don't vote no
places didn't they do that they're told
they have ticks and their they won't
show up and they're foaming at the mouth
they're all on fentanyl yeah if they
organize that's probably their biggest
problem though they're not organized
there's got to be one few sober homeless
people that are like man I'm really
missing out
they have weed homeless in La they don't
hang out with the heroin homeless
interesting yeah they're like now those
people how are you homeless from getting
high those dabs bro I mean damn that was
a strong edible yeah you're homeless for
smoking weed I just forgot to keep fake
I need to pay the rent what a [ __ ]
embarrassing thing to say dude I went to
rehab for Percocet and I was embarrassed
because everybody else was like oxies
you went to rehab for Percocet yeah
heroin how good is Percocet it's amazing
but it was gay like when I was in there
everybody's like I'm an oxy cotton
addict I'm a heroin addict I'm a
crackhead and I'm like I do Percocet
they're like oh you're gay
that's how I figured out I was gay they
were like you're gay when you start to
examine it like maybe they're like
you're a dumb [ __ ] no I'm kidding I
knew before that
yeah yeah I wonder what the homeless
it's like
yeah do you ever see one of those people
like start to kill them you know when
there's like a rash of it and everyone
kind of like we're gonna ignore this
story
oh I've never seen that there's like a
oh 10 people have shown up murder in the
last three days well they start fires
and I'm you know I'm not judging them
it's camping if you're gonna Camp you
gotta have a campfire but they start
fires and they in California they burn
things down like what valuable things
well they start the fire theater they
start massive fires that burned out all
these houses
good well just a bunch of actors so what
it's a way to think but Joe Rogan was up
there and he had to be evacuated yeah
[ __ ] fires before the homeless too
sure but anyway they started the forest
fires yeah
climate change is homeless people yeah
[ __ ] around yeah they're bringing
back the plague that's the majority of
what it is nobody wants to admit it
nobody wants to admit it they call it
pollution for businesses they're like oh
it's the [ __ ] whatever it's no it's
homeless people start fires
for fun because they're bored and then
they don't care they don't have a
community to protect it doesn't they
don't care they just March away and they
leave interesting
interesting you heard it here first
that's what's going on
it's true everything is true I thought
you're gonna re-up for it I went to
rehab for
so I was supposed to go for like 28 days
but they cut me off because my insurance
said he's gonna be okay so Seven Days
Seven really how'd you know you were
like I gotta go this has been two this
is too much I was um
I was at a point when I said
I should give this a shot give rehab a
shot give it a shot because you couldn't
stop well I didn't want to right right
but then I knew I had to
and I'm like if I don't give it a shot
I'll regret it yeah before it's too late
yeah
and I wanted to go and like you know you
feel as a drug addict you feel like
there's certain things you should do and
one of them is go to a rehab
also it's cool it's amazing it's cool to
say you went to rehab it's badass yeah
it's one of the my favorite things about
myself is that I went to rehab yeah all
the time I printed out this show is
sponsored by better help
you ever get sad
yeah but you know what happens sometimes
you just don't want to go to therapy in
person it's too hard to put pants on oh
my God you know that there's a thing you
can do online where you can get help no
there's not I've heard it there but you
got to drive down there you're wrong no
it's called better help Ari if you're
feeling sad navigating life's challenges
can make you feel unsure whether it's a
career change in a relationship or
becoming a parent my specials are full
of anxiety will people watch it will
people like it I need to talk to someone
but if you go to better help that's
better hlp better how better hlp.com Tim
D you're you will get 10 off your first
month
betterhelp.comd and here's the deal
here's the deal Ari yeah if you don't
like a therapist you'll get another one
you could just swap them out it's not a
big deal you don't have to tell them hey
I want to see somebody else like these
dumb [ __ ] chicks you got to be like
oh I don't want to do this anymore
exactly you're just so easy
I went to rehab that's cool as [ __ ] it's
cool it's such a [ __ ] Rockstar thing
of course having a drug problem or being
mentally ill is [ __ ] awesome yeah
it's one of the coolest things you can
do
being a boring piece of [ __ ] who goes to
work every day and [ __ ] pays his fat
families bills is gay
going to rehab
being a junkie it's so cool it is big on
the street it's just like damn
especially in the summer oh yeah way to
go if you're a kid Outlaw if you're a
kid right now and you're listening to
this show start
using drugs with the idea that one day
you'll go to rehab yeah you can just
clean it up do you have parents that
both work do you have a second car you
hope you'll be taken care of you're fine
you're fine here's the deal two of the
people I went to rehab with are now dead
really yes from what killing it so hard
drugs no it's drugs what happened to the
rehab they still did drugs after the
rehaster that's one of the big issues
with rehab well yeah they're like beauty
is taking a break so they left the rehab
and they their tolerances went down
that's what happened to Philip Seymour
Hoffman that's right doing his [ __ ]
College heroin when you got to do your
old man heroin that's right you can't go
right to their same dosage you go out
you get out of rehab do they not tell
them did they not tell you because they
should go when you relapsed him yeah go
half
I actually didn't
like when I got out of rehab yeah I was
good for how long I got into comedy oh
really yeah Oh I thought this was like
recent no what do you mean I thought I
just heard he went to rehab I haven't
touched him I haven't seen you in a
little bit I haven't touched a drink in
12 years because you're a loser
I I have things to do yeah Fair ferret
building an empire
renting out the lowest level Studio yeah
building an empire sitting in a basement
but what am I gonna do you know it's a
great Studio every time I come here I I
give I give um I I try to give I pay the
producer I don't pay a studio rental fee
which is nice that's not to it's best
not to don't give it up for thanks for
that guy yeah and and and I love Lewis
Gomez cut that and and that's why we
support this yeah but yeah I haven't
done anything in 12 years wait you
thought I was in rehab like last week
did you start a comedy out of rehab I
know the way you said it I was like damn
so [ __ ] cool I may go to rehab now
because now I'm thinking about what if I
go without a problem also money rehab
the rehab you'll get now oh yoga classes
the massages
the tropical fruit can you go to rehab
for being fat oh yo yeah sure yeah
absolutely there's fat rehab yeah so
I'll go to fat rehab you can also just
go to a resort
but then have a great time get fatter
yeah but if you go to rehab they'll make
you less fat you think so that's the
goal yeah if you go to fat rehab yeah
you go to drug rehab they make you less
drugs what two out of three dead if I go
to drug rehab sober already I'm just
gonna eat because no one will judge you
I'll just smoke cigarettes and eat I
want to go to fat rehab yeah you should
have you ever thought because you do a
lot too what would you do just celery
all day they give you like juices you
eat better at a drug rehab probably yeah
well I think in a fat rehab they'll ask
you like what are your goals
why are you here
what are the behaviors that we need to
stop
and you just go being fat right but now
they're like barely allowed to ask that
because the fat activist movement fat
shaming yeah I can't really ask you know
how great Americans are if big Fat's
disgusting yeah and then they go hey I
don't want to face that so I'll just
make it socially illegal to even mention
it I'll change the law around me all of
these things are ridiculous you end up
respecting
because at the end of the day you lose
like we're not gonna win it like this
thing with trans kids you're not gonna
win the next generation is all going to
be trans there's nothing you can do
about be stupid not to go trans a little
bit and they're gonna be fat and Tran
that's it oh no fat trans oh it's not
the worst trans dress like a model
that's the only benefit you go whoa
who's that and somebody's like look
again you go oh okay but they look good
no I'm looking bad
you're gonna have fat trans people
everywhere in every corner of your
vision if you can't deal with that leave
America you're fighting these battles
that are they're they're not going to be
one ever trans don't don't fight it from
the inside the community have a a an
idea that looks are important we need
your trans Community to keep us safe
so you're saying hot trans people yeah
they should bring back hot they dress
better than heterosexual woman yeah but
there there's a new kind of trans which
I don't even think you're realizing what
is it
that trans movement oh no yes these are
the unforeseen consequences the
non-binary movement that's not really
trans it's just kind of fat
and they have blue hair and they like
cartoons losers yeah well maybe well you
said that but it's losers and they're
like what do you like shut up I'm trans
or something that trans autistic people
are going to rule you and if you don't
like it leave America
and if I was running I would say that
I'd be like this we can't fight these
people we can't we have to wipe them out
kill them you don't like a 300 pound
gender non-conforming blue-haired Lord
of the Rings fan yeah that's gonna be
you know what they're gonna do they're
gonna make votes public so you can't do
a private vote anymore yes every trans
is going to win yeah trans black autism
and you sure it should happen
that's progress because
the energy to fight all of this it's not
worth it it's not worth it enjoy your
boat
go have fun yeah that's what I feel
about Russia Ukraine you're all worried
about the [ __ ] nuclear apocalypse and
I'm like I'm gonna be skiing I just my
whole attitude is like I would like to
not have one over the Ukraine yeah can
we stop pretending we care yeah make it
over like China Russia something better
I'm better some are cool Ukraine
nobody's going there
do Jews ever get to a point where people
are like you're [ __ ] cool now yeah it
goes back and forth right it really does
it Ebbs and flows yeah
every [ __ ] picture of a Palestinian
like 12 year old with an arm missing
from a [ __ ] shell going off that
doesn't help you guys love to kill the
kids you kill these Palestinian kids I
mean it's like nothing I've ever seen
Barry Weiss came on my show and I said
you know you bomb schools and she goes
and we also bomb hospitals we have to
and I'm like that's your defense because
that's where the terrorists are it might
have been opposite I might have said
hospital she might have said we also
have to bomb schools because she goes
the terrorists all hide in the schools
and hospitals like they're not gonna
bomb this and they go all right you just
kill these Palestinian children
yeah I mean they don't fight back it's
the easiest one if you've got to pick on
somebody pick on the week it's very sad
yeah yeah
yeah
cool it's like you said okay I'm gonna
even when I go there they're not it's
homeless and I'm not that offended by it
I have an agent no I'm kidding I I I
it's not my War it's not my fight I
don't feel I don't want children dying
yeah but like they their kids die too I
guess right yeah is there a way to say I
don't care without sounding callous no
to mean like there's no way I have no
caring for this issue it's not like I
don't care it's like it's like oh that's
not something I care about it actually
sounds horrible to everyone listening
right now that both of us don't care I
just got better [ __ ] to deal with
there's no good day in here is amazing
there's no good way to say that kids are
being there's armless children running
around and I don't care
what do you think about uh Israeli food
underrated it's pretty damn good yeah
the hummus
Falafel yeah and they're mixing now
their Fusion Arab and Israeli food is
there any truth to these conspiracies to
choose run the world or the media got
that please
what is that what do you mean I'm asking
who wrote The New York Times look it up
the salzburgers damn
okay one guy one Gentile
yeah we let one in and gas digital's run
run by we have Chris Allen at this point
Ralph is Jewish right no yes he is
oh yes he is Lewis is just a Puerto
Rican face of this yeah he's the face we
have Chris Allen at Norman's wedding and
was like oh here's our not racist
right Chris Allen forward so there's no
truth
it's like a group it is a group it's not
a group we're not in cahoots we just
kill it what do you want us to do not
kill it what about the Rothschilds they
they finance both sides in the war and
and went you know yeah I do know how
about that how about that we turn a
profit what do you want to do it's a
profitable business the media okay but
but why would there be there's an
anti-jewish articles why would we allow
that because it doesn't hurt prophets
from us
not having us from them what about these
I don't know the Rothschilds what are
you a self-hating Jew is that what they
call you sometimes right when I got out
I was like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you people right yeah yeah I hate a lot
of them it's a lot of what Kanye said it
was like uh this and that no one said he
was wrong they just wanted to be quiet
yeah you know
it's a complex and beautiful culture
and wouldn't say beautiful well you know
you know the the good complex they do a
lot of good things
the Holocaust Memorial
beautiful
let's get into that Holocaust because
here's what I've heard yeah
this is what I've heard and I'm I'm just
saying this okay just report on it
I've heard it was very bad
so far no issues okay okay what else
have you heard but it wasn't six
I've heard it was a six I've heard it
was four four I've heard it was four
that would be a nice exaggeration
because if it goes to 200 000 to 6
million you're like it's unbelievable if
you go to four million like we can up
this a bit I've heard it was four I mean
that Woody Allen joke and the scary
thing is records are made to be broken I
mean isn't he can we just say he's a
genius he's a genius he's a genius and
worth it
he did the wrong no he did the wrong
thing clearing our actress by Marrying
an actress but
you know
do you believe it was six million I
don't really know but it's odd that
that's an a very even number
it's strangely even it's strangely even
it it's like
it's like when you get hit with a comedy
check you know from whatever and they go
we had exactly 40 comps that's what
we're allowed exactly for it's like not
32 to the weekend why does the Holocaust
get more attention than the Potato
Famine which starved and killed many of
my people do you know I don't know total
IQ is lost
what do you mean you nothing lost from
the [ __ ] Potato Famine dude the Irish
One Step Above the Italian we have souls
so we all have stories yeah and music
and stories and like shalalys are nice
Blarney yeah no we are the the oral
history of telling stories of Keebler
passing down information is all us
okay isn't that blacks no it's not blood
what are you talking about stories in
the ships
if they were you guys were making money
off it
yeah someone's writing it down yeah like
they'll say this when there's movies
yeah I want to tell the story but yeah I
wish to get started with the story I
love all these dumb [ __ ] uh uh cultures
this is Stavros has the same [ __ ] they
all brag about the past whereas real
cultures are bragging about the present
oh we started storytelling what the [ __ ]
is going on now I know the Chinese and
the Arabs are the future
that's a fact the China you're killing
it but you know the Chinese are going to
beat the Jews Chinese don't have a
problem with us we're never been at war
with the Chinese interesting well will
Cahoots it till the end of time what
there's no issues there you love Chinese
food love Chinese because you knew I
started taking athletic greens because I
wanted better gut health more energy
optimized immune system I hated taking
pills vitamins wanted a supplement that
actually tastes great wanted to see what
the hype was about now I've been on it
for six months and I love it it doesn't
taste super healthy I mean do they look
at who their spot who they're asking to
read their [ __ ] Ari Health has nothing
to do with appearance you should be okay
the rest of you get the I should be
taking these it has kind of a mild
tropical taste that I look forward to
each morning Ari
you know get up in the morning so what
is this stuff with one delicious scoop
of athletic greens you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins whole Source
superfood sources to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one-year supply of immune support
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is listening athleticqueens.com Tim
Dillon again that is athleticqueens.com
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
we knew it was going to be available and
Chinese do not reciprocate that
they don't eat like Reubens no they've
never had a bagel never no they never
never had borscht or a [ __ ] quiggle
interesting yeah what the [ __ ] I had
cats Deli the other day it's amazing Oh
I thought you were talking about Chinese
and said I had cats no Jewish food yeah
delis oh my God smoked fish why it's
such a big sandwich
I know what my dad used to do he'd be
like get me some extra rye bread and we
split that sandwich into like four yeah
it's so odd you can't even wrap your
math around it how Jewish is that
splitting it into four yeah and the
right bread rest break the extra rye
bread this hour that everyone loves
everyone is saying this is a great hour
because it's about the Jews
I'd never thought of that angle heart
Ari I just smart cut that too I just
thought it was uh people giving me
comments but how could they say anything
but
now do you think it's because you're a
Jewish comedian you're allowed to have
your special name Jew like if my
discussion was called juice or hey Jew
yeah it wouldn't even get off the ground
you know my next special CD I'm just
gonna make a CD I talked about charade
uh it's gonna be called too many blacks
and the answer is what are the responses
from the Jewish Community to your
special Mostly they love it you have an
occasional like you know hate speech
person that's like that's just a fact
this could mean more anti-Semitism
losers dorks and losers right it just
brings people together but the vast
majority they're like this is great
thanks for thanks for sharing our
[ __ ] life experience all the [ __ ]
wig ladies you know are like sick nobody
talks about us not in a fun way
have you
gone into the bowels of the belly of the
Beast as you say if you've gone to
Williamsburg where they have the Hat you
ever see that furry hat yeah the strimel
what a [ __ ] amazing hat it's gorgeous
it's a beautiful hat you know those cost
like 1500 bucks I know now
Staples do you go into that area ever
and here's why they are not worried
about it because you can't get YouTube
on your flip phone
wow yeah
I forgot they're like Amish yeah more or
less they're just but they're on their
phone all day but they're cheating on
their wives sometimes like with fat
black hookers really I love a fat black
hooker whoa Pat careful a fat black
hooker is what a Jewish man wants love
it love it it gets so far removed from
what they're allowed right they're just
they feel like what am I doing that's
[ __ ] awesome black chicks in general
it's just like you see I saw him drop
him off some in Montreal right across
from uh
Cleopatra you'd see him late at night
just dropping him off because it's like
a shrimal and it's like this doesn't go
he reads as a rabbi and that fat black
hooker does not read as Jewish and then
she gets out of the car and she's like
what the [ __ ] it's so cool looking
it's kind of amazing it's kind of
amazing because here's the deal you're
born a freak you're born a freak you
don't you know what kind of community
we're gonna get and you gotta freak in
the [ __ ] Hasidic Jewish Community you
still need it
this gaze too of course and what are
they supposed to do what do they do hide
it
bath house right uh
I went I took my knees to a to a hike it
was near somewhere in New Jersey
and uh it was behind this mall and then
Woods go and we saw this dude six years
old comb over he goes oh hey uh probably
don't take her that way it's um
it's muddy
uh go that way I was like okay
go that we see two other like 65 60 year
old white dudes just sitting two dudes
on a bench later two other dudes and
it's a [ __ ] gay like Vietnam era I
have my wife at home
gay hang out in the park wow yeah and
he's like don't go that way because it
gets wild if you had not heard that or
had not heeded his warning we would have
seen some scarring stuff I would have
seen some [ __ ] yeah and there's got to
be a Jewish version of that
a place they know where they can go oh
absolutely yeah
yeah I want to know about that [ __ ] I
don't know what do you think about
religion in general what a waste of a
[ __ ] life interesting what a waste of
a life you know Rogan had this guy Matt
Walsh on and they were talking about the
game sounds like a dork gay marriage and
Rogan and him were just debating it and
it's just you do get to that point with
religion where they're like yeah I don't
have an argument what do you mean it was
a gay marriage not supposed to yeah it's
just wrong and rogo's like well what
should gay people do if they're gay and
then Matt Walsh was like I don't know
just
I don't believe you should have sex or
do anything like so the Jewish view on
on gay or homosexuality is that it is an
urge not unlike drunkenness and and
overeating well that's what Christians
say too every fundamentalist but most
Jewish men in the suburbs are very
effeminate like it's it's really wild
they will touch the whole massage no but
they also they're like hello I'm Barry
Allah this is my wife they're like I'm
fully gay but I'm not Allah like Jewish
men are insanely effeminate I worked at
a beach club in Long Island and these
guys would come in they're like hello
I'm Howard I'm Howie yeah you're right
the way you say it is borderline it's
absolutely true it's like oh you're gay
but you're not they're not gay they're
just Jewish because they're so upset in
it that they just don't care hello hi hi
what are you doing look at you
and then the wives are like more
masculine it's like I'm Eileen they
[ __ ] take a cockroach yeah they're
like I might lean this is my gay husband
[ __ ] yeah it's just like why are you
religious what are you giving your life
to God for well some people need it Ari
they need something
I had when I was studying with I had a
friend who became a rabbi and I asked
him for information for the special on
YouTube right now uh and and he's like
I'm not telling you
I was like what do you mean you have to
I'm a Jew and you're a rabbi I'm asking
you about the [ __ ] the law and he
goes no you're gonna use it to Mock I'm
not telling you wow I told him to get
[ __ ] wow yeah but this is their life
they've devoted their entire life to
this I wish there was a moment after
death before lack of afterlife where
they get to realize they were wrong how
do you know they'll never realize
they're wrong our side will only realize
we're wrong if we're wrong what a great
Point yeah it's unfair they'll never
know they were wrong yeah they're either
wrong or right they'll realize if
they're right they won't realize if
they're wrong we'll realize if we were
wrong and not if we were right
unfair well if we're wrong how do you
what do you how do you think it happens
what happens we get up there and God's
like
like the coming Mutombo just like nah
and we see a [ __ ] down escalator what
are the chances of that I feel like he'd
be cool what did I really do do you
think what did I really do besides
pushing kids every once in a while
[ __ ] you know hitting a car and then
leaving a fake note in the windshield
what did I really do everyone who's
governed any country
acts like there's no God the things they
do yeah think about it you have to
anybody Obama was able to go to church
and not be a complete liar knowing he
blew up a wedding party
come on get the [ __ ] out of town dude
you're Godless or your Satan if you're a
Satanist I get it do you think there's
an afterlife no do you I don't know
maybe yeah maybe I don't really care I'm
beyond atheism or agnosticism I don't
care I mean how do you not care because
it's like whatever it is it is I got no
control over it same as this [ __ ]
nuclear Holocaust I got no control over
it I don't worry about it you don't
wanna
you don't want some argument would you
like there to be an afterlife yeah
that'd be nice be nice I keep living
forever what I'd really like is like
Elvin where you just live for like a
thousand years like an elf yeah you just
keep living and living all your friends
get old uh you just kind of you you age
like a year every hundred
that would be a mate wouldn't you get
wouldn't life get boring I don't think
so imagine if yourself you live in a
life like an aunt where your whole life
is over like six months and you'll be
like well now imagine it's over 40 50 60
years like that we get boring you get
used to it you'd have a new scale wow
you'd watch your friends get old die new
new technology will come in you'd have
new friends
it'd be pretty [ __ ] sick but then at
the end it would be so wild what do you
mean at the end like meeting at the end
of this life that you've lived yeah
after you've seen all this stuff yeah
wouldn't it get sad and lonely
because there's nobody left to talk
about the things that you experienced no
they don't want to hear you you'd be
like one of those celebrities holding
Court
no everyone just be listening to you
yeah we'll get lonely you ever talk to
like a rich famous comedian and you're
just like you're just talking at us
yeah or a rock star or anything like
that yeah and it's like I get it you're
our betters but like man aren't you
lonely don't you want some back and
forth well that's the whole thing it's
lonely at the top right yeah yeah that's
what they say yeah not at the top of
rehab no
I want to go I would love if there was
do you think it's rehabs for juice
no there's rehabs for Jewish people that
have problems no no I don't mean like
Jewish base I mean rehab to not be so
Jewish there should be it should be yeah
where they bring in like ah it's
Christine Evans
how are you our owner of this place
um yeah there should be so she
interrupts the show yes interrupts the
whole show we had a flow going I don't
know she's not Jewish right no that's
opposite armo that is correct so what is
the opposite of Jewish because I don't
feel like I'm the opposite
it's it's like is the opposite of hungry
thirsty or is the opposite hungry not
hungry
I don't I've I yeah oh interesting yeah
so I think the opposite of Jewish is
like like a worm or something you're
saying she's the opposite because she's
[ __ ] right okay
we're on the same page yeah anyway yeah
the Armenian part is just like yeah yeah
I get it it's awesome what do you want
people to take away from this special
laughs buddy just laugh what about to
convert no we don't want you why not
welcome Jews we're good we're like New
York we're good don't move here oh crime
wave crime wave Patrice always said that
Jews don't want you to be Jewish no we
don't and why would you why because it's
like we got a special thing it's the
only thing that makes it special is our
small numbers but this is what sounds a
little conspiratorial because we have
ends that you don't have well no it's
just going we have and you know we don't
need you Christians we're like knocking
on your door like be one of us dude I
when I used to wear my yamaka yeah my
summer job
um uh some lady got black chick got into
a 50 years old got into the elevator
with somebody what floor She Goes do you
accept the Lord Jesus Christ your
personal savior I don't I don't you know
I don't that's why I'm wearing the
yamaka I was like what floor though she
goes Lord Jesus Christ loves all and I
was like okay that's good enough what
floor she goes I'm not even I just saw
you guys I know I'm not even like in
this building yeah that's Gall what
about Jews for Jesus
come on a little conflicted it's weird
right weird it's weird it's the greatest
two of all time
oh that's a good question Jesus is up
there he succeeded where no no one else
did Larry David's probably two
the Rothschilds
they built an Empire who are they you
know them more than I do oh I do know
them you know them more than that Maya
Rothschild who was he Nathaniel
um they were an insanely wealthy family
they get their money
well they were in banking okay when Jews
were forced into bank you know what so
what we're in Baker oh they're on the
back we couldn't do anything else other
than loan money I know so I was like
what do you want us to do not do that
well and they started you know they
started to get
popular juice thanks no Rothschilds oh
yeah when they were
you know they there was like five of
them and they each either the father was
like there was they were like you'll go
here you'll go here you'll go here what
different parts of the world uh yes
different parts of Europe
and they you know the they kind of
famously I think bankrolled both sides
unless I'm completely wrong but I don't
think I am they bankrolled both sides of
a war and it was France and England
maybe that's what they do that's what uh
politics does that with business they're
just like yeah just buy them both out
it's just a smart thing to do yeah but
supposedly they're trillionaires but it
they're not both sides or whoever wins
owes you tons more yeah
now supposedly they have a vast amount
of wealth but I don't know I'm cobbling
this together I mean The Message Board
they don't want everything out there
yeah they do not like stuff that's out
there that's a capital T they're not
like the car there's no show on the
e-network called the Rothschild they're
not doing like uh yeah a boss show no
they're not they're not on Million
Dollar Listing they're on squid games
they're on squid they want to keep it
low yeah and keep it quiet what's the
benefit of being known none famous many
negatives money has very few yeah
yeah so they're smart I know somebody
who knows one of them well who's a
Rothschild now like Bethany Rothschild
is there no there's a kid I know is a
rich kid in New York City went to school
with a Rothschild
there's Nathaniel there's duroth child
too what's that
that's the French version so they're all
made so much money yeah
they choose laws and stuff there's all
these conspiracies that they like kind
of own all all of the companies quietly
yeah but that's not true they probably
have a piece of it or it'd be like a
Harvey Weinstein thing it's like we
don't do every every movie but when he
was at his at his Peak but like don't
[ __ ] us or you'll be out of business
this should be good for the YouTube
algorithm a lot of Rothschild talk watch
always do on YouTube right now all right
should fears do on YouTube right now do
you talk about the Rothschilds at all no
not I don't know
I don't know anything about him well
he's fighting out right now I'll go back
and re-edit they're a big [ __ ] deal
the thing is with them that so it's not
like they're they're helping other Jews
they're like at the Illuminati table can
you get up guess digital producer get up
Lord Jacob De Rothschild confronted
outside of the Metropolitan Club I want
you to watch this guy he's kind of a
lizard guy okay and he's confronted
outside of this exclusive they let him
know who he was mistake yeah exclusive
elite club called The Metropolitan Club
started by JP Morgan not Jewish right
okay
and he's coming out of an event and they
kind of confront him wait so he was with
JP Morgan no JP Morgan's long dad this
was like recently JP Morgan the bank
that just dropped Kanye
Rothschild is a member of this JP
Morgan's Club well they all tired it's
all tied in though it's all tied up well
no now you're you're you're you're
you're being facetious do you have you
found anything
he's got to turn on the uh monitor I
told I made him turn it off right oh
yeah why did you do that that's
distracting I'd agree with it I hate it
but if we're going to see something we
got to watch this Rothschild get his
comeuppance wait what somebody threw
something in his face
well here's what happened no someone
went up to him and goes what are you
doing with you know with JP Morgan no
stop with JP Morgan you're getting so
confused you're doing this oh my God
where's bodyguards well
you know the New World Order has no
legitimacy and that we as a people are
not afraid and we are waking up to the
robber baron you should be afraid
do you have a couple minutes
where is bodyguards
I kind of like him
he's stand there taking it are you nuts
all
this is a [ __ ] garbage truck there
yeah
it really isn't true
there it is you know his accent is from
a country that doesn't exist it's your
country is somewhere between Normandy
I'm a Norman dude yeah yes yes but do
you see what it means bodyguards how
cool is he he's a real life lizard
villain when I met him maybe the owners
of the UFC who are [ __ ] penny stocks
compared to this guy right I got a bit
scared because I was like you could have
me disappeared yeah not that they wanted
to but the fact that I'm dealing with
someone who easily could and not face
any repercussions well Rogan this guy is
on another another level Rogan could
have us killed
sort of with his money he can't
he couldn't have his kills he doesn't
have the influence these guys have but
he goes casinos he could call someone he
could call someone he would know who to
call that could do it yeah any one of
our friends would kill us for money this
guy could whoever that's talking to that
guy he's like we're not scared of you I
want to be like you should be scared he
could vaporize he's looking at him go
hmm yeah do I want to where is it do I
want to eat yourself oh no no how do you
think I've lived to 200. it's just not
true live stem cells but that's kind of
what their deal is they run [ __ ] you
know who's married to one of them
Whitney
Nikki Hilton really yes get up Nikki
Hilton's husband
um wealthy Mary and Wealthy yeah of
course who are they gonna marry
of course they're gonna marry Marius
slobber Baron marry a slopper
she's married to one of the Rothschilds
he can't be maybe he's good looking
maybe he's good looking I think he's hot
I think I'm not sure because they
probably yeah because they're they're
offering will be good looking let's get
a nice photo of them and he's Jewish he
looks like Harry Styles
he's a piece
I'll trust her
that's what a little on Brett he's a
little inbred yeah he's got the vampire
ears and vampire nose he's he's in
that's who they that's who the Jewish
Bankers were in uh in Harry Potter
the Gringotts yeah pull them up it's
similar pull up the green got Bankers go
face to face facing each other and were
you offended at that I mean no but I
could tell what it was it's pretty
[ __ ] obvious and they're like don't
uh go uh ears just make it ears that's
what he did in Star Trek make it make it
ears the the yeah no no no no isn't the
way forward why'd he have to kill them
all he just gonna give him alone
raycon earbuds are the best earbuds on
the market they're better than the other
earbuds they're a lot less expensive
they have like eight hours of [ __ ]
Play Time have you ever had a ray Connor
bud in your ear raycon no raycon is good
dude
I feel like I have used it no you
haven't they're Wireless and they have a
comfortable fit they make it easy it's a
great holiday gift what holiday
Thanksgiving get there there's another
one Christmas one more Hanukkah it's
closer you know what everyone needs yeah
wireless earbuds raycon guys you want
someone sneaking up behind you of course
you do it's living dangerous well they
have all these they have all these new
modes where you can hear the rest of the
world and the music they should be able
to amplify degenerates behind you they
haven't elect they have an alertness
mode in a wireless mode yes it's all in
there folks go to raycon.com Tim and use
code early BF to get 20 off site wide
that's raycon.com Tim and use the word
early BF that's the code 20 20 off site
wide or save even bigger and get 30 off
raycon's exclusive holiday bundles do it
do the 30. everyone it's important do
the 30 not the 20. that's code early BF
at buy recon.com for 20 off that's buy
raycon.com for 20 they are great
headphones
I'm telling you right now give me some
anything wrong
they just had a bank who killed them all
Harry killed them all he blew up the
whole [ __ ] thing oh Harry Potter yeah
they didn't do anything they had to go
now listen
don't you think that you're such a good
Outsider now listen don't you think we
get over all this stuff by forgetting
about the Holocaust we stopped talking
about it it's enough already stop at the
museums it's very depressing don't you
think we just move on forward that's a
tough one I tell you what if my special
gets to 20 million views right then sure
don't you think it's 40 acres is done
pressing it's never ending I wish they
would focus on the pause of Judaism not
the [ __ ] negative well this is what I
mean I mean do we have to constantly
with the museums and uh and I mean I
mean come on I mean Jesus that's a Roth
child I mean wow oh my God by the way oh
my God does this episode stay up for an
hour even I want YouTube yeah I don't
know
John you from China and uh Jimmy tube
I don't even know but we're just having
fun comedians having fun we don't mean
anything Russians also respect it's
Hawk about these things because
they say you can't make fun of juice but
you can
we're doing it yeah we're doing it but I
mean you have one here to do it you
didn't do this last week with Bobby
Kelly I did not yeah I did not yeah off
stage though as soon as the camera
argued about if lakes or oceans were
better
I don't know we've all been talking for
you know a million years and what a
podcast gonna die already they will die
I think as soon as the celebrities
invade them and they're gonna invade
them we thought it would be any moment
the one guy tried but then he killed
somebody up close so that didn't work
it'll it'll get to what some will stick
around
but then I think a lot of it's just
there's no next thing yet right and
people always need they'll always be
podcasters always somebody's always
going to be commuting or on a treadmill
or watching something they like but what
podcast never became is movies nope or
TV shows they tried for a while to try
making TV shows yeah it's just my
podcast it's been a TV show people like
Stern did it it's just bonus features so
what it what it will be is when I think
people when there's a next cool thing
because young kids are on Twitch right
we're not on Twitch they're live
streaming
the young kids we're not [ __ ] it's
just that's their thing
they live stream
and that's what they do
can they get boners anymore
no because they're all on ssris yeah
I would sell my podcast to the
Rothschilds
yeah
and would you keep it going and be like
just deliver our message absolutely
absolutely let's practice Yeah
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show brought to you by the
Rothschilds oh it's not on the level
oh it's signage oh okay yeah uh ladies
and gentlemen welcome I haven't [ __ ]
no I was in Salt Lake and it's right at
my face everybody's gonna think I'm like
doing signals but my face is like
[ __ ] my Skin's falling off but ladies
and gentlemen blah blah blah approach to
you by the Rothschilds and then we would
be like I'd just be like pay your
[ __ ] bills peasants pay your bills
it's important these landlords get by if
Circle down effect pay the bills
it's it's the landlord is good yeah he
keeps the neighborhoods from crumbling
the landlord knows whether you should
live in the apartment or not don't
question him if if the gas is off it's
for a reason maybe you shouldn't have an
infant in the unit stop whining about
the prices of everything just go out and
buy it just buy just consume
thank you this podcast has been brought
to you by the Rothschild thank you
Rothschilds for bringing us everything
good in the world the progress
yeah man I don't know it's like the way
I look at the world I just say you know
can't you just not give a [ __ ] isn't
that a possible all these people black
lives matter the Jews thing you create a
[ __ ] Afghanistan got a new tattoo
yeah I got an Ecuador what is it it's a
flower that's in the jungle a lot
what kind of flower
yeah it's like it looks like lobster
claws I loved it every time I saw it I
loved it I was walking around there with
a machete once trying to get them and
this and I walked too far away from the
jungle and two into like what I like
about you yeah is when you get canceled
you flee the country I wanted to flee
anyway yeah but Delta was going up again
I was like sweet get it higher I'm going
to Peru when you get canceled you are
like in a third world country literally
hacking Through the Jungle not gonna be
having a good time I remember when
January 6 happened I'll praise the
heroes they uh they they were like at
the end of democracy and I was like [ __ ]
yes yeah and people were like that's not
our take on it now what do you like so
much about slumming around the third
world like a Savage you get to zooify
people you get to look at them as lesser
than you and be around them because you
go to like Safari you go to like a yurt
yeah yeah you'll stay in a goddamn yurt
with like weird freaks I take a 50 bill
with them I let them all see it I'm like
this is this is a change of [ __ ] year
you really you'll go to like Malaysia I
I have not been in Malaysia but I've
been all around Malaysia Indonesia is
Timor it's the same come on Cambodia you
go there and what do you tell them do
you tell them you got canceled
I've never got there they wouldn't
understand what that is people are mad
at me they're like why did you not
basket weave today yeah I'm like nah
they know who Kobe Bryant is he's famous
everywhere yeah yeah yeah I think you'd
be able to explain it like this guy I
didn't pass much he was a really big he
was sixth best Laker of all time when
you come back to America yeah
what do those experiences make you feel
about our country do you feel anything
legit the toilet paper it blows my mind
when I get back here I forget I take
that for granted until I get back here
from the [ __ ] horrors of foreign
toilets so when you get back to America
are you like where the [ __ ] or no
it's just overcrowded there are
definitely some nice things the toilet
paper is not a joke it's a joke but it's
not a joke you wipe and you're like oh
yeah I forgot about this
we have great like everything everywhere
but also it's like it's a bit much and
impersonal do you tell Joe says hello
because we have the same agent yeah he
hates it I leave do you ever tell him
when you're leaving
I told him last time when I left for
like three three four months uh what did
he say he's like no no no come on come
on come on come on hello can I get your
gig out there are there gigs in these
two more he's a good Agent yeah he is
right he keeps he keeps Junior and his
wife is gorgeous oh she's the best have
you seen his wife yeah she's like
gorgeous and great yeah she stays in
shape by not having any seconds and she
says like y'all and when a woman says
y'all it's good because you know you're
waking up to eggs and she's not
screaming about Sylvia Plath even you
can get a boner for that for sure
yeah he tries to talk me out of it but
it's like gotta live your life Duncan
says to me once I was fighting with
Comedy Central there I was like I want
to go see the world and but they're
[ __ ] yapping at me they're like we're
gonna be mad at you if you go away and
he goes Ari you want to see the world
and some business that's owned by
[ __ ] Viacom wants you to not see the
world so what's the argument even well
the argument is that make more money you
have her I mean if the Rothschilds
thought like that
I'm not looking to be that if the
Rothschilds thought like you where the
hell would we be where would everybody
be where would anyone what about the
benefits they've given us a society
they've given us what do you think about
Jeffrey Epstein and the Mossad it just
as we wind it down can you give a quick
link between the two the Mossad and
Jeffrey Epstein and the honey pot and
the blackmail and ipac and Israel and
then and the mega group and the Bronson
Family I know the honey pot you know
more terms than I do about the wealthy
yeah we converge on Jews and wealth you
love old wealth and and we are that yeah
but I don't know what day to day like
honey bite means you get stuck in it you
come and you [ __ ] somebody you shouldn't
we photograph and you and video you and
then we blackmail you you're right smart
I think it was a massage operation
killing Harvey Weinstein are you in the
Mossad
you know I got a call after uh yeah from
the Israeli like intelligence agency
after the Mossad there's a writer
pretend not to know the name name
Arielle shaffir and he writes for Seth
Rogen
so every time there's like he does
something like some calls or
congratulations and after they did a
thing with Korea my parents got called
at home from the Mossad and said we need
to talk to your son and they were like
it's not him and like ma'am
we need to talk to your son wow that's
how unintelligent they are
I can't believe that
I cannot believe the Mossad is
unintelligent I think it was the Israeli
intelligence agency and not the most
yeah yeah yeah so then maybe it's the
it's the they always got the Holocaust
guys though they always got the Nazis
the ones that live in Argentina live in
the good life they just get a bag over
their head one day like what the [ __ ]
massage
they're the best they're the best they
kill it they kill it literally yes any
parting words about Jews or the
Holocaust or the roths don't focus on
the negatives in the past focus on the
good things I should focus on this sucks
you go [ __ ] yourself you're buying
store-bought matzah you need the [ __ ]
handmade 30 bucks a box I do I actually
need that yeah I'll get to that and peso
what about lavage
it's like matzah
I support Jewish dollies I love them
yeah I love smoked